gmail is what i'm on now that's the uh
you got the most space for attachments
anyway thank you feel free to hit me up
if you remember that number i noticed
you ain't write that down
damn damn damn that girl was fly right
shy
but did you see that liam nieces movie
with them wolves though the one with
them big ass wolves and liam nieces
[Music]
oh liam neeson's straight jacked up
moves [ __ ] wolves
and don't even get me started on that
one when they took his daughter
straight talking starring liam neeson's
man leave me on the phone like i have a
certain set of skills
and the second one the russians come
after him and he [ __ ] them all up
anyway took in two starring the
incomparable liam neesons
that's my what about doc man no no huh
what about liam neeson's in some dark
man no
what about darkmoon when liam niece's
face was changing
homie was straight face changing now
that's just liam neeson's acting right
there man straight up i kid you not
academy award caliber classic me since
seriously i mean like nieces already
need to have a statue you and me since
ain't got no he got a statue he ain't
got a statue he ain't got a statue no no
no
the oscar goes too liam neeson's dark
man face was changing how hard is that
ain't hard dog it's not hard at all
that's stupid
balance it
lisa's straight killed a robot boat liam
neeson's is my shit's knit
but you know who i like as much as nice
sisters as much as nieces who
bruce willie
bruce willie is like
oh what if they made a movie with liam
neeson's hey i'm bruce willie
nieces and willie
glee and nieces man harder
fat wood
yo what's up game of thrones though dawg
yo
you all caught up
totally biz watched that whole thing
last night nice door oh it's called
bloodied up in westeros god
i mean my man was just there right
he got
and then i was like i ain't worried they
gonna kill my boy ned stark slip and
then plop i was like
yo i told you they cold blooded up in
there and then i was like but that's
okay because i still got my college logo
big
i mean he big like hercules and
everything i'm like you can't kill carl
dragos with a paper cut an infected
scratching
scratch but he got straight killed but
she's yo but you know what my favorite
character is
khaleesi's police
you know i'll be liking some khaleesi
star but what about khaleesi's
straight up with them dragons
khaleesi's with these tactics and
khaleesi's all like this and then we
talk about it
just great roasting goats
oh my god
i mean that's when they start killing
characters left and right going after
wedding
fighting monsters what his wife what he
got his mind yo
killed killed killed
that was a
what about the hound dogs
yo but what about my man's taiwan
lannisters
taiwan lannisters i want to answer stuff
yo my man
by his own son what
the dinkles saw
the dingles dinkles down the dinko the
dinko stinkles is my jam ain't nobody
killed the dick they think cause it's my
jam my jelly my peanut butter and my
peanuts thank you guys
dinko's though
dinko's is my
[Music]